[Music]
just one more reminder to subscribe to
the spectators youtube channel it's free
then you'll never miss a new episode of
spectator tv because you always get
reminded that there's one
has just hit youtube and you can do so
by subscribing
hit the subscribe button in the bottom
right corner of the screen
now in may a black man called george
floyd was killed at the hands or should
i say knee
of american police his death triggered
months of protest sometimes violent and
destructive
many also peaceful and gave renewed
impetus to the black lives matter
movement as ever the uk imported the
cultural wars of america it wasn't long
before statues
here were being toppled and calls to
defund the place were levied at the
met though they didn't get very far in
mainstream politics
now underlying much of these activists
worldview
is so-called critical race theory
now you might be familiar with some of
it already that western institutions
are inherently racist the white people
are structurally
privileged that the british syllabus in
schools and universities is colonized
it's a
controversial theory many have
criticized it is popular in many
academic circles and among
some activists but is it right is it a
theory of substance who better to ask
than trevor phillips
former chair of the equality and human
rights commission
one of the authors of the 2010 equality
act trevor phillips thank you for
joining
us here on spectator tv just mark my
card
give us a better summary of critical
race theory than the one i just gave
thank you andrew thank you for inviting
me and i wouldn't even dream of trying
to
better your summary it was pretty damn
good um
i think the way that i look at it is
this as you will
undoubtedly know i'm pretty much a
skeptic of critical race theory
and i'm a skeptic for this reason if i
were a white nationalist who wanted to
discredit
the progressive anti-racist movement i
would invent
critical race theory why number one
it says to white people you were born
with original sin
and there is absolutely no way that you
will ever shed
that sin so give up already
you are just racist and basically the
only thing you can ever do
in one of the bibles of critical race
theory um
robin d'angelo's uh book uh white
fragility
she says the only thing white people can
do is be a bit
less white by which she means a bit less
racist
uh secondly the other reason second
reason i just
i dislike it is that it's antithetical
to scholarship
i mean one of the key aspects of the
text of critical race theory
is that it has to have no data data is
uh an and an obsession with words i
think is the expression
are said to be uh characteristics of
white
supremacy so actually what critical race
theory is based on
is narrative anecdote what happened to
me
and my feelings and actually all of this
all of this adds up to two things one is
distraction from real issues like pay
gaps and so on
and secondly an obsession with
individual feelings
none of which none of which will change
a single thing
for people of color on either side of
the atlantic
let me unroll some of these things but
before i do trevor
one of the things that strikes me about
but particularly its depiction of whites
uh that they are just irredeemably
racist and there's not
really much they can do about it except
to the uh
the margins it reminds me of a
calvinistic
predestination it doesn't matter how you
behave in this world you want
it's predestined whether you get into
heaven or not it
doesn't really matter and there's a bit
of that about critical race theory
well look i mean let's be clear it's a
scam
it is straightforwardly a scam uh you
only have to go back to reading
tom wolf's uh male mowing the flack uh
um uh malmo flat catchers in which he
describes that the way the black
panthers
essentially took down leonard bernstein
and white new york society and played on
their guilt
in order to raise money for the panthers
by the way i'm full of admiration for
the enterprise
but this has absolutely nothing to do
with improving the situation
for people of color and here is the
other thing which i think is
particularly pernicious it makes the
issues of race equality
entirely about white people it is
entirely about what
white people do entirely about what
white people feel
people like me simply become pawns or
bystanders
who sit here begging you andrew please
be
nicer to us that's the real problem with
critical race theory
it's great for the academics who sell
books and can go around
go around guilt tripping white people
but for most people of color
no difference whatsoever now i take your
point because it does kind of everything
is benchmarked against white
and it doesn't deal with all the huge
inequalities we see in britain's ethnic
communities
say between a kid from china and
chinese parents and a kid from
anglo-bangladeshi appearance none of
that
seems to to matter at all one of the
things i mean i'm not qualified to say
whether it's right or wrong but one of
the things that depresses me
about critical race theory is that it
seems to pay
no regard to the progress that has been
made in a country like britain
now we know we have still a long way to
go and there's a lot more we need to do
for opportunities
and deal with racism where it still
exists and no one can deny
that it doesn't but you're you i was
brought up in the 50s and 60s you you
were brought up
not that much later we know how
much this country has changed and
changed for the better and
it seems to me if you say nothing's
really changed then you
you just kind of give up whereas if you
think actually you know we've done quite
well we could
have done better we've done quite well
let's do better now
that's a message of hope yeah um by the
way just if i can just make one point to
you andrew and also to your
listen you began that question by
slightly apologizing for being white
you don't have to mate honestly honestly
it's cool i'm i'm
you know i'm chilled with it it's of
course you're never therefore going to
be as handsome
or as strong or run as fast as me but
that's you know that's your problem i've
learned to live with that for quite a
while now
yeah you'd have to apologize for it um
but i think i think your point is a very
important one
and from the point of view of somebody
like me
in my family and the 10th of 10 children
my
parents and my oldest brother who my
brothers who were very active in the
anti-racist movement in
the 50s and 60s it's kind of
disrespectful
to them every time i hear one of these
people say
oh nothing has changed they literally
have no i
idea my brother ran home from school
every day
being chased by teddy boys you know my
eldest brother
ended up in wakefield prison for his
anti-racist activities so i think it's
utterly disrespectful
to our parents and our forebears
to be going around saying oh nothing has
changed and by the way this isn't
another facet of the way that the whole
black lives matter movement has
essentially been taken
by white people because they feel it's
okay to disrespect us it's okay for them
to go on twitter and call me a [ __ ]
because that black lives matter gives
them license to it
but there's another very important point
which i think ought to be made here
the problem with a lot of the black
lives matter propaganda is it does not
recognize that britain is a very
different place to the united states
and here is one extremely i think
significant
uh factor in this country
there are getting on now for a million
people who have both
white and black parents or grandpa
grandparents
that has not happened voluntarily
anywhere in the world
south africa has mixed race brazil has
mixed race
populations the united states but
they're all out of croatian and slavery
this is the only country
in which a population of that kind of
that size has emerged
since the war and somehow saying to
those people
actually your mum is just a basic a
racist because of what she is
just i mean it's sickening no no the
intermarriage has been
hasn't that been a great british success
story
well you know we can we can talk about
the details of it but the fact is it's a
particular
thing about this happened in britain
that we ought to recognize we don't know
by the way what this group of people are
really going to emerge like and how
what they're going to be like i don't
know what it feels like to have
two different heritages in my background
my children do
and i think that will make them very
different people to me but we don't
yet quite know what that represents i
would think it will probably make them
21st century
that's the way it's going i wonder if
there isn't an even bigger agenda
be behind the not so much black lives
matter
but after this whole critical race
theory
because it does seem almost to try to be
aiming daggers at the very heart of our
being and our existence in our history
so
britain it will always be irredeemably
bad because of the british empire it's
just something you can never
shake off end of and if you look at the
new york times the
1619 project which was inspired by a lot
of critical
race theory they picked 1619 a very
important date
many people did not know enough about it
was the first slaves
arrived in the united states it is a
critical day it is the original sin of
the united states
but it then goes on to to to argue
that the purpose of the revolu american
revolution in 1776
was not to free america from a colonial
york
and become an independent self-governing
country it was because
the slave owners were frightened that
britain was going to abolish
slavery so they had to break from the
british to preserve slavery now as a
someone who knows quite a lot about
american history uh i can tell you
that's
complete nonsense there are a couple of
slave owners
in the south who might have seen it that
that way and actually britain's
anti-slavery
credentials were nowhere near strong
enough in 1776
to be able to conclude that but if you
see what they've done
the very foundation of the united states
is not built on freedom anymore or in
becoming
an independent country it's built to
preserve slavery that goes to the very
roots of the country
yes and that this this relates to two
specific two points that i've
made one is the complete lack of
scholarship i mean it's just
what as you say it's complete drivel um
and actually
their understanding of the slave
experience
is utterly deficient um i mean for
example one of the things that nobody
really talks about is the fact that um
when we
talk about slavery today in this country
and something in the united states what
people are reflecting
and thinking about are slavery in the
caribbean rather than the united states
now this this is a rather kind of geeky
point but
most uh american slavery was cotton and
tobacco slavery
small farms almost no
uh american uh plant of farms
were huge you know like you see in gone
with wind with a thousand slaves and so
on
i think probably a fewer than out of uh
forty five thousand they're fewer than a
few hundred that had more than a hundred
slaves
whereas in the caribbean these were huge
factories with thousands of slaves
so they understand understanding and
this is important because
actually what is true about the united
states and i think they the black lives
matter movement has missed a trick in
this
is that the terror for african americans
occurred
after the abolition of slavery that is
when the kkk emerged
that is when the lynchings happened and
and what we're seeing now with the
police
is an inheritor of that rather than
slavery and i think they've just missed
a trick
actually because they haven't understood
the story
but more i guess more importantly than
that um
politically we'd think of black lives
matter as
or we talk about it as though it's an
inheritor of the martin luther king
tradition it isn't
we should think of black lives matter
much more like extinction rebellion
because a basic proposition is like with
extinction rebellion
you can't have um you can't have a green
world under capitalism the the
blm line is you cannot have an
anti-racist
society uh under capitalism
never mind the fact that in cuba there's
still never been
much of a black presence in the
leadership after her how many years a
slave
of uh of socialism ditto
you know my brother got beaten up in
moscow long before that was happening
here
i mean they want
they're being used essentially as a
front for people who want to overthrow
things as they are and in a way that's
one of the reasons i slightly resent it
that actually these guys don't really
care very much about whether black
people
are advanced or not what they want is
for us to be
a battering ram for their desire to
change society
i'm not against that you know i'm i'm a
lefty
but do it honestly don't use us as a
as a pawn i i certainly think it's true
that martin luther king would not have
been
a supporter of critical race theory i
wonder though i just finished up on this
point slightly left field
i wonder if malcolm x would have been a
supporter of critical race theory
well funnily enough i i reviewed a new
biography there's a new biography out of
a very
interesting biography it's a really
interesting biography um
i think that malcolm x would not have
been a supporter of black lives
matter because he wouldn't have liked
the in discipline
of the movement i mean he believed
strongly in proper discipline
i think he would have seen
some sort of commonalities with critical
race theory
in the middle part of his career because
his view was you couldn't trust whites
and therefore we need to be separate
from from them
and in that sense the notion that you
know whites carry this
original sin he called blue you know
people quote uh by any means necessary
all the time they don't quote him saying
whites are blue-eyed devils very much uh
he believed all of that
however of course after he had
gone to mecca had hajj
gone round uh with the seven hills
with hundreds of thousands of people of
all background he wrote about this
incredibly movingly
dropped the whole idea that whites are
intrinsically bad you can't mix with
them all that kind of stuff
um so i think at the end of his life
short life unfortunately
he would have been really pretty hostile
to critical race theory
and also he would have recognized them
for chances yes exact
and i think it was a pity was a short
life because he was an evolving person
and uh and he had still so much more to
contribute
trevor i we could talk all day about
this it's been a joy to have you
on tv come back and see us again it's
always
great to listen to you trevor phillips
[Music]
there
[Music]
you